today I learned that every three-on-one
complaint police and fire department
incident bike share rides street tree
and filming location in San Francisco is
now available in a bigquery public data
set I'm reto Meier Google developer
advocate join me as I explore the city
by the bay with bigquery SF fog city
whatever you want to call it it's just a
short traffic and just to drive up the
101 from here in Mountain View so grab
your jacket and let's head for the
Golden City
really come on in 2016 there were almost
a half-million 3-1-1 calls in San
Francisco compared to over two million
in New York so clearly there's a lot
less to complain about out here on the
best what the capita San Francisco home
to over 800,000 people is a city that
makes good use of its three-on-one
service using the municipal complaints
line two-and-a-half times more often per
capita than New Yorkers the most common
complaints in San Francisco are for
graffiti and requests for street or
sidewalk cleaning while bulky item
pickups and illegal homeless encampments
are the fastest-growing complaints San
Franciscans are getting less easily
offended within offensive graffiti
complaints on the up well there's been a
significant drop in offensive graffiti
the SFPD data includes more than 2
million incidents since 2003 so we know
that as we head down Bryant Street we
should keep an eye out
theft from locked cars accounts for over
17% of all reported crime incidents in
San Francisco and Bryant Street is a
notable hotspot picking on fridays with
most reports filed at lunchtime or after
work this heat map shows the worst
places to park if you're planning to
leave anything valuable in your car and
want it to still be there when you get
back it turns out a lot of stuff goes
missing here on Bryant nearly 20% of
filed lost property reports are from
Brian Street the best odds for finding
something is here over on Valencia where
more than twice as many items are found
than a reported lost meanwhile on hate
the legalization of cannabis could see a
7% reduction in the number of arrests in
the haight-ashbury neighborhood in 2016
26% of all drug-related arrests in San
Francisco were for marijuana but as you
can see drug arrests and down 62% since
2003 with only methamphetamine arrests
trending up 2016 marked the first time
meth became the most common drug
involved in an arrest here in the city
with access to details for more than a
hundred and twenty thousand sidewalk
trees we know that you can get a taste
for Monterey by visiting Sunset
Boulevard
leafy Street in San Francisco home to
nearly 1,400 Monterey pines and Monterey
cypress SF is a shadier City the new
york featuring 2600 trees per square
mile
compared to new york's 2200 but they
share the london plain as the most
commentary in both cities for cyclists
this trail along Embarcadero is the most
common path for Bay Area bike share
riders in San Francisco after looking at
nearly a million trip records we learned
that San Francisco bike sharers spend an
average of 14 minutes per trip almost
the same as the 15-minute average for
New Yorkers will blame their steep hills
for the slower average trip speeds here
in the West Coast the four million fire
department service calls show us that
the most common location for a
structural fire is in the Tenderloin
while the best place for it to happen if
it's going to happen is in Chinatown
where the average response between
calling 9-1-1 and fireman arriving at
your burning building is an impressive 4
minutes 30 seconds compared to a
citywide average of 6 minutes and 8
seconds big shout out to the crew of
Engine 3 of the 4th battalion the
fastest engine in the West with an
average response time of just over 3
minutes thanks to the City and County of
San Francisco's open data project and
Bay Area bike share Google bigquery's
public data sets now include over a
hundred and fifty gigabytes San
Francisco public data for you to explore
as always your first terabyte of
processing is free so fire up bigquery
today to investigate San Francisco and
share your results with us using the
today I learned with bigquery hashtag
and as always subscribe to our Channel
and follow our blog to learn something
new with bigquery
you